oro talco malton al sudore bella a tutti
i ragazzi
benvenuti avessero video sono fa vj e
oggi sono un gioco che non ho mai fatto
tanto avete già letto dal titolo quindi
effetto sorpresa a [ __ ] nate ragazzi
sono su faim le tetre disco loculo swift
quanto pare sì se fa united 3d super
loculo swift e togliamoci sta roba
perché partiamo perché shumpert allora
ragazzo è la madonna per gran figata
giuseppe ciao ciao detto cazzo ascolta
c'è un computer stai zitto che mi stai
futuro c'è già one night express frutto
di suo figuriamoci così cazzo cos'è sta
roba da dietro non c'è grazie a dio
dietro non c'è niente però non vedo
quindi non lo so cosa faccio luci porca
[ __ ]
c'è figo va bene ragazzi abbiamo capito
che non è così easy come pensavo
e quindi devo io devo accendere le luci
e vedere se c'è gente fantastico proprio
il gioco che che sognavo di giocare da
da un secolo meraviglioso dove sarebbe
computer a questo e computer questa
catapecchia della mi chiama ci gira
metal gear sta roba qua zio a io devo
chiudere per controllarsi
fatemi controllare un secondo no perché
sono mica armi in mano ragazzi se mi
spunta qualcuno gli schiaffi in faccia
ve lo dico ma non c'è la minchia che poi
è tutto oscurate allora chi è che non
c'è più freddi bene ok ciao zio ciao
ciao io sono fuori j piacere vi supplico
calmi e guarda i quattro denti davanti
consigliarti un dentista noè
eccole fratello la porta la chiudiamo
inter senti frate se ti consigliamo
dentista e non sono io il dentista era
un altro dentista ok non capiamo ci
possa accendere anche questo sino ciao
zio
chiudiamo qui è perfetto comunque sei
molto bello anche tu complimenti
complimenti alla mamma e più incassi in
atto di quanto pensassi ragazzi per
essere sul loculo si rifà da dieci nomi
spunta qualcuno ma perché potrebbe
essere questo se n'è andato un posto che
non se n'è andato marco per il bene vi
quindi se sono alla finestra non vuol
dire che che mi stanno stuprando non
arrivare alla porta fantastico per
ragazzi e il rimando chi arriva a
[ __ ] a non posso perché se non
finisce la dall'energia scherzava
scacciava chiude o cazz o scherzetto
loro talco malton al sudore cosa non hai
capito della frase io non sono il
dentista non so te lo chiedo va bene che
deve essere reale
questo gioco contiene jump ma dai
veramente grazie alla grazie mille per
chi guarda mi hai cambiato la vita
a differenza di tutti gli altri fai da
te freddy's in questo bar velocissima la
notte in due minuti dell'amica già ho
finito problema è che va veloce anche la
batteria che si scarica come la minchia
guardalinee cosa state calmi costa luce
pagate le bollette perché ci sono dei
funghetti vuoi farti di funghi un
telefono che probabilmente l'iphone 7
poi c'è questo computer che è un
prototipo del 2017 che fa girare anche
metal gear col buco del culo ciao zio
vuoi un po di coca fratello non quella
che pensi quella che ci sta sulla
scrivania noi ato poverino veniamo così
dove cazzo andato prega il problema non
è il mostro in se il problema è quando
non lo vedi più cazzuto come che se n'è
andato a caso è possibile dai ragazzi
ti prego ma sei ancora ai rami per il
culo a strozzo la giunta a marzo
ma che sarà strano ma che ho sentito
moltissimo ma anche dai che manca un
cazzo vecchio di e forte forte sega mi
puzzano le ascelle celato fra il fare
c'è la dovrei farcela forza forza forza
forza forza forza da inizio a te c'è
bottari che stava degenerando la
batteria ma ce l'ho fatta
grazie bimbi grazie mille sulle mani per
farli j anche quelli che ci hanno
lasciato le pesate dive di coriandoli
frate sotto ti per mezzo adesso anche un
po per te anche un po per te ammettiamo
quella difficoltà ragazzo shamo hard
prima così dai che ci sono mi sento
prodi se il tuo stomaco si sente strano
chiama mamma e papà adesso non lanciare
torte non tagliare sulle porte non
abbracciare gli animatronic allora non
lo guarda e io mi hanno detto che non
posso abbracciarti quindi basta nel caso
di cazzo non mi toccare ti denuncio ti
denuncio molon volevo farmi leggere non
lo smacco fine di reggere che ha visto
anzi un po di privacy numero lascia
ancora e chi ha palle sono al 35 per
cento di batteria vi togliete un po dal
caso per favore grazie bene 24 per cento
ragazzi sono le tre di notte non ce la
farò mai mai l'importante è partecipare
vero zio buttava lì fai masturbando
pratt e non me lo so che trashata era
accusati entry senza permesso minchione
se mi stava masturbando è ci pensi a ste
cose
l'ex it andiamo a mangiare guarda frate
volentieri per andrea schiavi tana
l'altra [ __ ] però sembra mia madre
la mattina quando devo andare a scuola
che entra così era modalità ultra frega
niente ancora più difficile aumentiamo
già non riesco a far questo ci provo
ragazzi ci provo
la pazzia la [ __ ] porca
no no ragazzi no no no no allora sono
sporto 6 sexy club e golden freddi
è una roba scott hodes io non so chi tu
sia ma mi sei sul culo non c'è neanche
la bocca cosa vuoi neanche la bocca
pretende di parlarvi razzista con le
persone che non alla bocca vice
correggendo il rumore del campanello di
casa tua
va bene così ragazzi son contento
chiudiamo qua perché non si può
impossibile però che vi sia piaciuto
essere un po strano però dovevo farlo
con la onlus perché dio mio ho fatto
tutti i tipi fai da tè freddi se
esistenti al mondo
mancava questo spero che non sia
piaciuto ragazzi il concludo che
episodio se video è piaciuto questo
l'assortimento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e coniglio trattenere
tiziana susseguirsi di sky noi ci
vediamo al prossimo di bella ragazza